motor center crowd let him know
[Applause]
well Lillard started all this remember
was 61 against Golden State and
sprinkled in there that five-game set
was the triple-double in the home win
against the Houston Rockets Terry's got
one two three four players getting set
to come in Luers going to stay on the
floor with 239 remaining he's got a
couple possessions he gives one more
basket
eight career 50-plus point games
at 49 at home
with 36 minutes logged in blank sites
free throw is off Darrell Brantley with
a board and up come to Utah Jazz who've
waved the flag
[Applause]
there we go
[Applause]
and here he comes with 49 proud rising
to their feet works along the edge
you toss over the limit Damien's going
to go to the line
remember he went to the free-throw line
to get 61
so here he is now he's got two chances
to get 50
49 point
we came into tonight's play an 88% from
the
milord six of six on strike tonight
deep breath bend to the knee staggered
stance it's up it's in he's got 50 50
points for Damian Lillard
Hassan Whiteside will come out 17 and 21
boards tonight
Lillard goes back to the line 451 yes
sir
2:16 left salmon's we'll come over and
touch up and a foul that allows Willard
to come out and get a standing ovation
from the crowd here too
damian lillard with 51 listen to the
crowd
[Applause]
well that is just something special